in its magic to see you here it's good
for you okay convention appearance
that's right yes well in America and in
other countries in Europe but not the UK
so far very enthusiastic very very long
used lots of people with lots of stuff
we want signing some very humble it's
been a pleasure to do the ball and
continue to do it I think until six
o'clock is that right yeah
and is this is this a quiet day because
you're currently in the West End I'm
yeah I'm in a play at the moment in the
heart of London in the West yes I guess
some of your biggest story till the few
times that I was at home minding my own
business and the phone rang and my agent
said George Lee just wants to see you
just like the saying oh really
pulled up outside my window and he said
oh they're sending a car I said I think
they sent one so I went upstairs going
to car went to hell street had they
started cheating on that very first
movie
Episode six that I was in and I met
George Alisha park with the director I
went to provide anything lots of weather
permitting present and all my way eyes
like a woman hanging it could be that
nothing you know and he said oh yeah
thanks for coming great those have to
put it on your next thing and then when
I got home the phone is ringing again is
my agent and you say you've got the part
I said well that's exciting
what's the part he went oh god I hope I
booked through his nose he said it's
called the Emperor of the universe so I
said it well guess I'll be doing it
better and the rest is this year
there are no small parts I didn't have
to turn out to be for the paper then not
many people get really good at that
stage we have made up I think cast
somebody else how dare they but they
were looking for the oldest person in
the world at that time I was only 39 or
something like that because someone who
was in his eighties a wonderful actor
called Allie we're no longer Wizards
but he couldn't take the contact lenses
tests because you know I wore yellow
eyes so they couldn't be sure him so in
the very last minute
in front and then we celebrate a great
place marry selling the casting director
of his early films I do her quite well
actually also see you play a very old
man at the theatre upstairs roles in
London politically don't know it's a
very small theater and in fact in that
ideas close to the audience as I am to
you now a property player am i played
the aging decaying [ __ ] news and I
had to look about eight years to say
that the movie was about the whole law
that said marry so that I guess she said
to join but I never confirmed this with
it I know this guy who's in his 30s who
would be believably very own so they
were getting that's how it happened but
I had quite a high American voice in
that and they're the accurate voice at
all as we went into filming and
originally I thought that I might not be
allowed to Keeney's because as you will
not know the voice has already made its
the voice made it appearance and it
already he heard in Empire Strikes Back
and that was flying all the way my hands
and I got a tape library a bit of
marking said if you get your voice play
surprised they've been that you keep it
I didn't think that are gonna take it
away however by then I started talking
with the ebiz voice at Derby it's a
storm so I said I just like go on doing
that if nobody jacks and I did and then
we went to the post a pic in those days
might see people hole in the film was
read out just because of
a fan of digital recording now as you
know miracles could be worked so I
suppose that this final decision had
been taken that that could be the voice
that will be finally in the movie and
behind without the dubbing session a TRS
alcohol digital digital coin there was
George of course at Steven Spielberg
abstract of a messenger boy I've used
very charming shot there and I did a bit
at UN oh my god you're evil and I think
it was I think it's at that point I knew
and got the voice too good so that's how
it all began we asked about me died
quite young lady a tragically I forget
see he don't even a couple of films it
was a heart attack or something
described it was very sad and a big loss
to movies was he was really very good
adjoins they had wanted someone to who
he thought could work both skillfully
with the actors and we felt he was able
to do but the problem of that is of
course it and abilities to say you know
I'm the one doing the geometry and
everything that had to be done with us
at the fitting the grand plan our pilot
was all going to look and feel at the
end of it so it's a kind of uneasy
relationship and if they go on well but
that's really why George on three balls
lots of talk about other directors
coming here decided do all three because
it was all in his head at every time you
know you have these blinking of the
director that history can happen about
goodness and he thought the hell with
myself the day of my birth it was
brought up here by industrial time that
he and I suppose I was about five years
old a variety show Palace Theatre don't
need like but I got to go to Miami was
the stage manager I didn't know what's
going to I think they were theaters like
that led be exciting point and I saw
this Scottish topic is called Tommy ball
and I got to meet him backstage argument
and in those days people were a lot of
my account you'll play as well so there
lies could be probably see in footlights
so because I didn't realize that till
I'm messing my physics like young kids
seeing it's loud am I wrong scary at
same time is something really
fascinating about it and I think that's
when I got the part
a relic gets the part that's so long
there's something in what he does that I
think I might be able to do and I
suppose that that's the journal when it
but it also it's like a magician showing
you the track and so in the hold is a
little difficulty front stage and
backstage because he almost admit is he
divided the Khalifa's you know it's
baloney stage but I couldn't see how it
we go so I thought it was some magic
going on underneath the dancers feet and
I thought every time they could have put
on the stage they make this amazing
sound so that when I was sure how it
really worked that was slightly
disappointed because I realized it
wasn't magic over the city continues to
be magic full of surprises like that
and I always think it's a pity that
these days everybody wants to know how
it's done or you know it's spoiler alert
what's going to happen hey hey relax
surrender to the magic allow yourself to
be amazed and surprised and I still feel
like but also the fact that you were
inspired by because you went I say we
met back home you back say yes yes I do
and I like it of course we rather play
you like obviously the blame at dr.
stack I excited by hoping the star wars
over God because if anything I don't do
except occasions like this but I'm
always very happy to sign over theater
itself in some other films as well
would I be right saying that your list
of theater credits is longer than your
list of movie growing yeah absolutely
and that's that's my first love really
being on stage in fact that living
breathing people being a living really
person myself yeah and also in that
context sorta you know we've learnt our
lions you know there are job but
anything can happen I have to pull water
coffee table you know some nights it
holds on top of me some nights of who's
very near the front of the row I have to
grab it back it so it's been literally
anything that happened and the
interesting thing I think people talking
to companies here to go understand
everything you do or don't do in your
Victoria we here on stage and we are the
uses of
detective Dawson is a mobile phone but
that's what makes it live exciting
interesting words in old movies they
take what you do away in a little cause
you know treat it deal with it and then
you see a letter that's great that's it
so ignited magic I've seen quite the
Infernus towers and I ever be useful in
a professional world where you in green
were more impressive how people react
have other actors take my own psychology
trying to work out of the building but I
think I think the great thing is of
course is you know it was the first
worldwide franchise so it's a reference
point for everybody even the very few
people who have watched it
nobody you know the battle of good and
evil
I just have to correct a few of those
people you know that the most evil
creature in the universe wasn't the type
of a it was me so you better hope you
come to see me repeat myself like that
but that was it's not you could find out
that I was even more evil with all
pegasi I wasn't sure initially Turner's
yeah that's now I've got no doubt about
it whatsoever
I think the first time I spotted you
without the Mary Hart you were playing
the Dennis Potter Alliance and I think
it was at first yeah that's right he was
a complicated series of by the writer at
the writer in the series was writing a
television playing a bunch of writer who
wasn't unlike Dennis Potter and I was
like in a bit so that's one
but I regulator number content-based
like BBC and people would congratulate a
book Beatriz Montero 90 several facts in
highness
I'd writing something else at the moment
later there was one occasion because he
used to write brother brilliant
television plays what was the what is
sexual or had a great great wasn't a
retirement fund a new project and alive
is the BBC I'd forgotten but I will take
this commissioner said to me I don't
know what will say about you I think
you're great
and I think there should be more sex on
television you know I never idea what it
was talking this is dirty man BBC Robert
Gates advantage you know I realize you
saw on the tennis court since you could
have sex on television is like quite
substantially yes it's only like the
Lord in that curl yeah I have to correct
you to my fury
I'm afraid the person who's been in all
six and he's in episode 7 his Anthony
Daniels
so we hope he holds the record but they
lose never will the likes it but I
please God you never will but for all
our sakes
my kid is pretty taut education
I didn't want not to do that fight
sequence with good to go great
gentlemen I have playoff sir and when I
didn't learn any great detail didn't
expect me to be as athletic as
subsequently I got technical and I had a
very good stunt double who is also a
little bit like me and that is no
because it start out with I don't mind
you had to do with actual stuff and be
serious in closer and then of course I
saw him today
radix be and I'd be training for six
months you know I got you McGregor few
tips you know my toe hey no he youth I
got thirsty honest I was lucky that day
I said lucky still to be open seats
because we shot sequence where I turn
into the monster and I've had four
witnesses driven at me that's what
you're talking machines are like in big
films I know that hair if you pose with
stuck on you know goes put the thing
that they also get or don't pay
attention to what they put it they come
towards you with Samantha's gusts when
they also bring how fast you go
downstream and that goes down your
throat so I get sort of hobby speed
after I've done that in to be safe as it
is only one day a believer I thought two
years before this comes up it all has to
be done today and then on top of that at
the end of that there is did you see the
author of the paper with the cameras on
me I thought one of the count is on
maybe at work today you know on Friday
which it was they'll do here monkey
healthy business
and I said to Joey I'll do my best I
didn't even jumper hers I got lights in
my hand and I said my voice might might
go at any time - our goal is destiny and
he said oh well you know if it does
we'll worry about that later
I thought they would fix it but that
mean common I wanted regular labor the
last time I saw it all I came here is
the dust in my throat and I mention it
to George oh it's okay Mike
he said it was just great because he
thought package that was hidden in
transition that was the Senators Italian
grazie
so if you leave a conservation kept
falling music - dr. prochik equal
territory and try to concentrate on that
scene at the end of the day with two
terrific cabin and just in front just of
the level you are now because they use
the film most of my stuff from the very
unflattering below position so I could
look like Rupert Murdoch Kokichi p.m.
you say anyway in order to the state is
possible in my golden succeeded during
the 20 takes I think Oprah gave the Sega
CD compelling is the only one a ver mile
segment talked about for time and of
course it was introduces however I
thought well that was a bastard good all
over again on Monday and so I came in on
Monday all set to do goats mov like it's
fine regarding now overly long that's
that's a very good thank you
it's a strange question
maybe exist a moment that someone have
had
friends ask you okay am I want to watch
Star Wars review the universe who
watched any episode from Star Wars
excitedly odd friends but I do remember
when I went to the first show because of
true sharing my legacy friends that
makes your neighbors apart at that very
small son who see the first cell with
those and he just refused to believe
that I was in it because he couldn't
relate to that you know I think I think
next going as an actor I could possibly
install movie beauty well it guided it
upstairs
I said no I am rivets love take me long
to the coast
so you still like two pigs until I came
up to speak how big it to like myself I
heard about the divorce but then you
look to be late for the next seat I get
back to Italy where I thought I will
without so much doctors he would speak
to me it speaking about three weeks but
certainly to this strange creature he's
all I accidently probably already dug
his grave so that purpose that was the
one experience when I watch your little
friend
I think turning up our stories from my
family I know that my son enjoyed my
mother-in-law when we need to see
episode 1 and down the microphones you
said that your question is theater
see you doing about you me yeah
yes I just get angry
well of course we make a play you don't
act like you know it's all very polite I
spent a long time trying to get the
right hand but sometimes he would i i i
think other people's I'd live sofia most
celebrated my own particularly
responsive to her golf earnings the
expert at living potential if you
probably know Hispanics place we did the
play this is right is right isn't
grateful components and the segment
often people died and he said just help
of we're busy and carried on I hope ho
ho ho recently happy okay I think he
also had an interrupt with the phone
which kept ringing and then kept ringing
and he said again the igniters pop star
of American Lawyer if you go down to
that highway I think he enjoys I think
you consummate the audience Irving into
her society I must have had a few but I
might not because he really try not to
you know just live off the stage the
auditory you're gonna drink it something
happen to have my hat to be yet in this
riotous
if we want to go on Patel aesthetics was
hi Ashley it was there a very subtle of
Star Wars practice in that one of your
lines you've got quite a bit of emphasis
on once at the line there might have
been I think doing the dark side wasn't
it yes okay I just what I say this word
existing he went you know grab the time
how does for anybody like you might make
it out but we hope that the evening burn
yeah I said that's a great that was
cautious about yeah Socrates room
hip-hop yeah yeah our actors I have to
enjoy super work in the animation
Department is really impressed and do
something somewhere or have you don't
know facial or Canady before hunting
when I was approached by Angry Birds to
do the Emperor's voice I could verify
Somalia and took me so I opportunity say
they bought myself a little bit and that
was fun but by mods I I wouldn't them I
wouldn't take the Emperor's voice and
you were accepted to another Star Wars
baby I know I do not have anything sorry
yeah and the perfect is I think much
voiceover were told I also
but you wouldn't play along even
attractive so to reclaim what is there
any any sort of courses that you have to
do to jumpstart not really of course
even even do it didn't tell me I was
Darth Sidious in the first movie so Emma
I got the script I got his services
wrong was because look we had a second
story that I just married right foot
cradles that he's just like the first
except even shorter and he didn't make
me to talk about my nose because he get
ready to see it too many times on the
roll over in the kitchen so I said
something for advanced enough but he did
say in this you know you don't become
the monster for a long time and good
be playing a straightforward sensor he
said far as I'm concerned if you just
play or what the ends of my smartest
later on they may find out that mr.
hypocritical and I said only citizen
early filling as such he said well there
were hungry dogs said one of them is
longer
tell me about really emotional expert
say well I don't think that would be me
that he said there's another one so I
thought well I wish I was playing that
offense of course I discovered by walls
unlike miss the rest of the cars they
may amnesia we will be went to the
Crimea in London said you didn't tell me
you were playing in and so that's that's
how Star Wars secrets that not be there
but you know after the filming and if
any of you follow me together pretty
silly don't you
but George said a very good thing about
playing the same time and said well you
know when you play now series a key play
Everett yes Jenna at the time Jane like
you have glass eyes well if you sort of
sacred the Senecas eyes as not being
green as being sort of maybe made a
glass of something if that's event used
and I just fantastic at least more so
miss X I think of my own face with your
a little bit of makeup happy
oh gee boys as a mouse so when I came to
put off the month of the Emperor you
know that in the sense that versus to
yourself and that was very useful to say
how would I do that stretcher the odd
things in my arm but I'm not always
filming that was in my hair I serve a
useful forget boy to play existed that I
didn't give away anything that I didn't
something happen at the evil good past
my place but every now and again you
might see so the that was always a very
but someone you doesn't think he's a
director like yourself is it really good
the Ranger said it's pretty good
question I think the great thing about
being a true if you can up he doesn't
come on people but when you have the
opportunity to it's more alternative
lines an eternity ways bigger countries
time and how about a theater argument
they disfigure the two minutes worth of
film so you're able to go on to another
plane plane an actor everywhere I've
experienced things maybe some other
it's probably the biggest individual say
you have the opportunity to put it in
terms of cheese and other bionics I mean
I'm very lucky to have a broader base
career as I have to be in the Star Wars
saga
I had to play any different very parts
in the theater at our television since I
quit it look like that's a plane I'll
put an applied for television series
Antonio you take you to I won't tell you
much you might convert and I mean any
spoilers to go but Town Hall the
Commission is rated stars lose to a
mafia ten o'clock 10 o'clock plays
addresses a lot of likes it gives women
and that the second episode is the
following night 50 90 tension I like the
character he's like a it's not hot like
starlings i watch series 1 FF it's very
good and I never write quite well and I
didn't know I was it when I walk by and
now I am so that whole might explain if
you watch on Tuesday night so that's a
nice that's another example of something
that you know just came up out of the
blue
watch it something that was good
wonderful fellow actors and so on that
having a very cool kid is later
realizing that you were in Istanbul oh
that makes no sense there's nobody by
making sense of you watch be more
masculine airplane senator and a
politician Palpatine who are you a
senior politician often might like their
private room the after all
realize I wasn't really very hard we're
pretty not by hard playing hypocritical
politician you know you've got a wide
variety to choose from
I was just trying taken somebody who
seemed to be the best
okay the nicest the best straight
forward actually Democrat heaven thank
God he was not moved in my head well I
you know I really could excel politician
so I'm sorry but we've also time but you
probably right well as you all might
once L was arriving the rest of your
lives
I feel that it's at this time maybe the
filming I always say the day off yeah I
don't get that
thank you that category is that nothing
to Kevin the Star Wars universe you know
like no I'm gonna be boy I'm not a
definite of the night as amazed a by
then I know we believe the occasion
hologram from coal arrested at this no I
put you know they can take many twists
on the story
I see use their own voice we don't you
and I guess it may go back to a time
I've got no clues and just be healthy
talk to my hair what the ever regular
there I hear what anyone else
so it might have been good
I don't be employed how about me or I
didn't read it
the answer is yes you uh put one of the
about some problem you took all so
without glue and then possibilities
that's why I quite like being in the
state of you know suspenseful surprise
pencil utensils right but not see longer
please let Betty school doesn't work but
yeah I know yeah I wake up thinking you
know I'd like to be visited by mine so
there are various parts that I think my
ages of the supposed to gravitate
towards and they usually wonderful parts
and for that very reason I said not to
gravitate towards at that time if one
take my way I'm not gonna mention it I
might I might not about resisting I'd
certainly like to go she ate
at the North American trade just did its
work that kind of line use and also try
making as much that is he as accessible
as I live in a sense is like speaking to
you now I think that's one area
challenges like this many great ways
alive for people today I thought that
they should come out of a sense of duty
or they helped the house that you say
they don't want to carry out a good
thing if they don't have to do it so
it's not that the government practice
today is very very early suspect I might
have a chance together go to my director
it will be 1998-2002
and that was very exciting that is it
was great because he could also be a
taxi won't work if you work if you
really like that expensive very funny
do you know he's happy they're all gone
and the customers say yes return Jax
doesn't forward she that's the
conventional stage for the other two
stage the altered by becoming them but I
should not gonna be the next election
but you don't decide for a big cities
that it might be great interesting
that's right so my god now what did you
think about playing with a cheap budget
movie like Stephen Harper and the
different world
you know the Star Wars saga one world
and another one yeah diverse great fun
see how it was the interesting thing
about that having come from my beloved
little dream state
I may be wrong but working again on the
huge realistic sense Donna does not have
released them I mean they both would it
was so beautiful I can't think that
Marquez even look on stage that we went
down with him that they put the business
degrees so everything on the site was
fantastic they detailed and realistic
for the inside should I leave but they
copy the props director so on and things
like that so it's like there's something
up using a secret oh you didn't have to
imagine that it might be there two years
time we got a doubt that they take sin
sadistic well it was also full of a lot
of actors knew each other well good luck
like my diabolical a bit significance in
the sacrum it's guaranteed to make you
love not to mention the only deadly by
using fine acting too so it was it was a
very joyous season and so you might not
have a lot fun realize that the final
camera to be think if I know that was it
that was a good day to be it's always
always good to look forwards going to
work and I'm very much look forward to
having me today
continue thank you for making your
personal paper
you